all right Ben Davidson of suspicious
observers welcome it's such a pleasure
to finally do this with you let's give
it like five ten more seconds to make
sure that I'm live on both ends can you
do a refresh for me to double check that
stand by we're gonna make sure that this
is all good to go
standing by
are you doing a Refresh on the
computer
everybody that's listening all right so
we're good on YouTube
waiting on Rumble let's see here should
be good
rumble's good all right everybody we're
live this is Ben Davidson of suspicious
observers my name is Jimmy corsetti with
bright inside Channel as some of you
know but Ben Davidson is a gentleman
that was an attorney and a former life
and he went down the rabbit hole and has
been sharing amazing information
involving cycles of the sun catastrophes
on Earth uh he's led me down this Rabbit
Hole to see that the big Missing Link
involving catastrophes on Earth is
involving sun cycles and he's also the
gentleman that introduced me to the Adam
and Eve Story the CIA Adam and Eve story
so many have become uh aware of
involving pole shifts and the cycles
that they've happened on Earth and
completely cataclysmic uh nature in
which uh Earth has found itself so Ben
hello it's a pleasure to finally do uh
be doing this with you our father or our
followers have been waiting on this for
a long time and uh we're gonna be
dropping some truth bombs here tonight
aren't we
yes we certainly are although we're
probably going to have to be a little
careful while we're still on YouTube so
that you and I don't have to
um you know use the fallback plan of
starting an only fans channel right hey
I'll talk about the pyramids uh like oh
you know this is how the Egyptians uh
built the pyramids I'll do one one
button at a time and you know you got to
make uh ends meet somehow and by the way
to everyone listening so this is now
streaming live on Rumble and YouTube
site simultaneously however
approximately a half hour or so in we're
gonna move it to rumble and it's for a
very good reason if if people are not
paying attention now is the time and I'm
inclined to think that everyone
listening right now is fully aware of
the reasons why we are living in an age
where you can't speak the truth because
if you do they'll go like this to your
career we've seen what happened uh with
other notable people recently and Ben
you know I follow you on social media
and I would encourage people to go
follow both of us on Twitter your space
weather news on Twitter correct
uh yes space weather news at Sun
weatherman I don't know why you have two
different names on Twitter I I still
don't know why they do that or I guess
it's now X right it's it's now right
I know it as Twitter but um I was seeing
you recently tweet though where I was
going with this that they're first
they're coming for so and so then
they're coming for the Tates and then
they're coming you know and then they're
coming for us oh this is how this right
like this is how it works like
throughout history whether it's you know
any totalitarian dictatorship regime
it'll eventually all go down to the
state where nobody will be able to share
news or information or teach unless you
are a state-sponsored character and they
are coming for all of us like this is
literally if there's anything the
history has taught us is that it repeats
itself it's not cliche humans are very
predictable and the powers that be will
eventually the censorship will just
continue into Oblivion
um so with that said what do you what
should we be worried about where where
what's the current state of affairs in
this world involving cataclysm
censorship
um we can dive into censorship when we
go over to rumble maybe but um what are
your thoughts what's your forecast well
the general theme is we're in trouble
um we're in trouble from a
from nature we're in trouble from
a civilization perspective we're in
trouble from a spiritual perspective as
a people
um
if it seems like the world has gone
crazy faster than normal if it seems
like
people who have a lot of power in this
world appear to be both Satanist and
pushing their agenda harder than ever
you're right but the reason is because
they're watching another clock
um and that is the clock of the Sun and
uh yes there's a hand that's played in
there by the by the Galaxy and the
galactic magnetic field but
um
essentially what we've got is
as you were mentioning there are these
Cycles on Earth and
some of the more important ones are 1
500 years 6 000 years but the most
important one is where they sync up at
12 000 years and that is basically where
we are right now uh it's my opinion that
you know one of your favorite topics
Atlantis it's my opinion that this is
what took out Atlantis about 12 000
years ago
um
and uh great shout out to your work on
that by the way I think you're really on
point with uh the rishat structure and
everything
um I think there's some evidence to
suggest that it was a vast Empire but in
terms of the capital or at least one of
the major
um major centers of that Civilization I
think you're right on point
um
I really appreciate that Ben
um and I will say like I agree with you
like I think it was a global
civilization I have another friend uh we
have a mutual friend Nikki Anna Jones oh
yeah yeah she she says she thinks
Atlantis was an Epoch of time and I'm
like yeah I think you're right it was a
period of time where the this world was
much different and you know I tell
people like as far as you know the eye
of the Sahara Rashad structure being the
Lost location of the capital city
um when it comes to the nature of pole
shifts this is one thing that's got me
further away from the uh younger driest
Cosmic impact Theory although I think
it's very possible or even likely that
the Earth got hit by something in that
period of time when I look at that water
erosion that blasted the Sahara Desert
that to me is not the result of some uh
meteor or asteroid hitting the
Mediterranean Sea in a flow of you know
tidal force of water I think geomagnetic
pole shift which I think actually moves
the the continents and the crust you
know about which would cause these
tsunamis and other things
um and we're gonna I want to hear your
thoughts on all that but my to me where
I'm going with this is that you know
Atlantis or not something happened to
the Sahara Desert and what imagine what
would have to have happened to create
that type of water erosion for say
potentially a tidal force one to two
miles high according to Adam Eve story
like so share your thoughts on this a
lot of people aren't aware like I've
been seeing your work and you talk about
the cycles of the Sun and how through
electricity it essentially will unlock
the Earth's crust and then it ties into
the pole shift and everything else can
you explain how this works because
you've opened my mind and eyes to
something that pretty much no one else
is talking about like I've heard Dr
Robert talk about cycles of the Sun and
solar flares but like
um the more and more studies I'm seeing
come out are literally corroborating
exactly what you've been saying so share
your thoughts of how this works and a
lot of people again are hearing this for
the first time so just nail us with it
sure
um and we can go into some of the
details and some of the studies but just
from a big picture perspective
uh
it looks like a major Blast From the Sun
that happens about every 12 000 years
since such an electromagnetic shock
through the Earth that it actually fully
melts where the crust and mantle
are touching each other you know we have
the crust here and then the mantle below
it and from a strictly chemical
perspective from a density perspective
there would be no reason why the crust
wouldn't sort of bounce around and Float
around on top of the mantle like plywood
on a lake but there's this area where
they're touching where it's kind of half
melted or 60 melted or 30 percent melted
and so it kind of sticks together it's
it's best described as a thermoelectric
equilibrium because there's always a
significant amount of electric current
going through there and it's very
temperature based
we already know that when we get the
modern day solar storms which aren't
cataclysmic it induces that electricity
all the way down into the mantle and so
of course this major blast is going to
do the exact same thing and it's going
to do it to the point where it fully
melts that layer and the crust is free
to actually shift around now
this is what has been described by
people who are talking about disaster
for hundreds of years and it really kind
of got scientific about 70 or 80 years
ago
um two important things happened
at one point we had actually Einstein
and several other individuals doing the
math on it they were all very convinced
that the Earth's crust has changed and
shifted and tilted many many times but
they actually wanted to figure out how
this works and they figured out that the
ice weight at the pulse was probably one
of the main reasons why when you have
something that's spinning like the Earth
if there's any part that's heavier than
the rest it's going to want to spin at
the point of greatest centrifugal force
which would be the equator and so if
you've got a crust that is no longer
locked in place you've got the ice caps
wanting to come and spin at the equator
and drag the entire crust over with them
while that math was being done and it
was simultaneously attempting to be
covered up by the CIA or at the start
the office of strategic Services you
know the OSS proceeded right CIA right
uh and while that was going on one of
the most important military figures that
virtually nobody knows about was doing
incredible work in the Arctic his name
was Major Maynard E White
and he was working on Project Nanook up
in the Arctic and the whole idea was
okay well what if Russia comes over the
North Pole and so they wanted to
establish a presence up there but they
also realized that in order to do that
in anticipation of an aerial battle they
had to learn how to actually navigate
around the magnetic pole it doesn't
matter when you're flying across the
United States you're flying across the
Atlantic the magnetic pole is generally
to the north but when you're actually
flying around the magnetic pole
all of a sudden all the traditional ways
of navigation go out the window and so
they were tasked with finding and
studying the magnetic pole and what they
found was
that had been starting to move and was
continuing to move and while they were
drilling down beneath the ice into the
sediment they found these layers
separated by about 12 000 years and the
top layer
was mostly Polar fossils but below that
was tropical fossils then polar fossils
and tropical fossils and polar fossils
and tropical fossils meaning crocodiles
yeah meaning like every 12 000 years
that region was tropical it was at the
Equator so that sort of suggests the
tilting back and forth of the earth and
they tried to cover that one up too
because there's very there was another
interesting military guy who was up
there with major white and his name was
Admiral bird
and during that time is when Admiral
Byrd in his book claimed he flew into
the South Pole and into the Earth I
don't know if you know this story yeah
at the time he says that took place he
was actually in the North Pole with
Maynard white doing right and so we have
Einstein and several others doing the
math on how it works and finding yeah
this actually does happen we can
actually make sense of the observations
of the world turning over and then we at
the same time had major white up in the
Arctic actually finding these different
layers and so essentially that's the
crust that's moving but the ocean isn't
attached to the crust it's just sitting
on top of it it's like if you've got if
you've got a bowl of water and you just
all of a sudden go like this the water
is going to slosh around pretty good and
I think that's probably the best
explanation for the tsunamis including
the one that that took out Atlantis like
that dude that's amazing and and what
you're saying like people listening like
people have to start using their own uh
logic to consider what it would take for
example like I was just mentioning a
second ago it's like they're finding
crocodile fossils uh in in the Arctic
like people have to like sit there and
and contemplate we would take like they
already know that pole shifts have
happened and so one thing I'm can you
clarify they're trying to mask it as
geomagnetic right like
geomagnetic pulses have happened
hundreds of times uh you know there's a
shift in the earth's uh you know inside
the you know the inner core and it
causes our compasses to be thrown off
and they they always try to emphasize
that it's not going to be cataclysmic oh
sure it could cause some Satellite
Communication issues and and stuff like
that which that would be cataclysmic
I've said 100 times now I'm like if the
satellites go down like the lights go
off in telecommunication systems fall
apart like say goodbye sayonara to our
way of life now but that aside what is
your explanation so like they'll say
geomagnetic and that's it where are they
right where are they wrong like how does
it tie into the actual movement of our
cross
so
you know they do try to paint it as
though it is just a geomagnetic thing
where it's just the magnetic poles and
the crust doesn't shift and
you know it it's part of a cover-up
that's been going on for 70 or 80 years
and
from the risk standpoint to the
biosphere the life on Earth
the the papers that are coming out in
the journals can't hide from it in fact
all of the most recent ones including uh
my favorite which came out just a couple
years ago in the number one geophysics
journal in the entire world I was
talking about how these geomagnetic
events are the main
cause of species Extinction right at
least on on these on these uh you know
multi-thousand year time scales and
you know
we had one happen 12 000 years ago
called Gothenburg we had one happen
about 24 000 years ago called Lake Mungo
Mono Lake Le shop the vostok Greenland
event you can basically track these back
every 12 000 years with more minor
events on the 6 000 year half cycle in
fact they just several months ago
discovered the one six thousand years
ago it's going to end up taking the name
the China event because that's where
they found the the uh the evidence for
it and you always name the thing you I
mean they always name the thing after
where they found the evidence
um but yeah so this is the thing that
the papers agree is a major problem and
it's a major problem I mean even if we
forget about the fact that the crust
does shift and it lets the oceans attack
the continents let's think about what
else is going on this is a major player
for climate I mean
in terms of sunlight coming in in terms
of electromagnetic energy coming in in
terms of ozone destruction in terms of
space radiation bombarding the ground
it's a major issue
it I mean we don't get very much
variation
um in terms of space radiation here on
the ground in modern times but we're
talking of 40 80 200 percent increase in
space radiation we're talking a 30 50 60
reduction in the ozone we're talking
major lightning storms the kind of
things that scared our ancestors into
thinking that it was literally God being
angry or developed the stories of Thor
uh right we're talking about
the mega stories from our ancestors and
this is something really interesting
we've built our modern society on our
ancestors math their architecture
geometry philosophy but we take the
stories that they said were the most
important
and we write them off as fantasy it's
like they flush it down the toilet
that's what they do they laugh it off if
you can't I can't say anything out of
the Bible and and I've said this I'm not
a bible thumper I don't consider myself
Christian I am a believer I am a
believer in that I come from the source
of all that is I'm not going to go down
like the spiritual path this early in
the podcast we'll get to it but I'm a
Believer and that we are a source of we
come from creation and an intelligence
that is beyond our understanding and so
I don't like to be lumped into like a
category of religion
um but the reality is that there are
there are uh verses in the Bible or in
every other religion major religion
around the world that says that there
was a deluge that said that something
happened there's even ones that allude
to a pole shift as you and I have talked
about personally like the time when the
sun uh Stood Still and and the in Rose
in the west and they'll say they'll try
to cough that out and be like oh they're
talking about death that's where you go
when you die you go into the West I'm
like it says that the sun Stood Still
and then like later on uh it Rose in the
west and sat in in sunset in the East
I'm like let's just ignore that they
just wrote that down you know if you no
one would have believed it back then yet
people took uh they went to a profound
extent to document and preserve that
type of literature
are they just are they just fools are
they just stupid people because that's
how they write them up oh they're
they're dumb they're they you know they
were they were living in mud huts and
wearing uh loincloths for clothes
they're dumb like just ignore them it
was too long ago they're dumb they're
stupid
um I'm not so sure that's a that that's
the case um
I obviously agree with you I obviously
agree with you uh some of the
zoroastrian texts are phenomenal when it
comes to this
um
some of the best stuff in the Christian
side of things is actually in the
Gnostic texts Book of Enoch chapter 65.
and Noah saw the Earth turned over and
knew its destruction was near
yes that that's about as clear as it
gets
right
and so
we can get into some of the details
about
how this is happening or why this is
happening and the fact that it's
happening not just on Earth but on every
planet in the solar system it's
happening on the sun and there's a
galactic reason for it there's a reason
why it's clocked so perfectly and that's
due to the galactic magnetic field but
it's also important for people to
understand that what's going on
culturally economically politically
socially all of this is tied
to this event
in about every way that one could
possibly imagine and
it's one thing to just take the
scientists approach and say okay I'm
going to look at geomagnetism I'm going
to look at climate Cycles I'm going to
look at astrophysics I'm going to look
at the planets I'm gonna and literally
seven or eight different fields of
science start telling the exact same
story but then when you take a look at
what's happening
in our culture and then you take a look
at religious texts and you realize wait
a minute this is the exact same story
that is full in the Rock in fossils and
that we're watching play out before us
in the world today and it's
there is no other field of science that
can make a claim like this most of
science says you have one vector of
evidence one vector of information and
you're doing your best to make a guess
or a hypothesis about what it all means
this is literally seven or eight
different fields of science this is
modern observations this is religious
texts of all different kinds all telling
the exact same story
let me let me interject real quick
because I want to bring out my phone
because I was looking for one particular
verse so Joshua 10 13. so the sun Stood
Still and the moon stopped so the nation
Avenged itself of its enemies as it's
written in the book of jashar the sun
stopped in the middle of the sky and
delayed going down about a full day
so
like to any Devil's Advocate like
listening that's like oh no no I don't I
don't believe that the Earth did a
topple and flipped over
what does that mean what's that simple
as symbolism of like to me I'm like I'm
reading it I'm like now that we know
that like these pole shifts are a real
thing it's like I think that they're
telling us this and to me I'm like a lot
a lot of people are very on board that
there is a cosmic impact that hit the
North American ice shelf uh called the
you know the younger the the precipice
of the younger driest uh catastrophe
where there was massive freezing to
happen 12 800 years ago before a warming
uh excuse me warming 12 800 years ago in
a cooling 11 600 and I'm like you know
that makes a lot of sense for a lot of
reasons but I'm like if it had hit the
North American ice shelf and caused
rapid falling based on the nature of the
earth when did it have refroze like
wouldn't it have to me I'm like it seems
to me that there was a shift that would
explain the sustained nature of that
fine
um and then we also read this this is
from the Quran real quick he who seeks
repentance from the Lord before the
rising of the Sun from the West uh Allah
turns to him with Mercy now people will
say just to clarify they'll say oh this
is referring to death I'm like they're
literally talking about the day that the
sun turns to the wet or uh will rise uh
from the west and I'm like well that's
the day you're gonna die like that's the
day we're all gonna die you know what
I'm saying because it's like when that
happens I would I'm inclined to think
that a and I'm just throwing out numbers
but 9 out of 10 people around the world
will die but be some corner of the Earth
where someone's on some Mountain they'll
be okay and someone else on the next
mountain is gonna tumble
um and and not to get too sidetracked
but when I think about like the
dinosaurs for example if they died from
a cosmic impact which I don't disagree
with that that happened in that period
of time but there's essentially
mountains on top of all these fossils
now mainstream science will say well
yeah you know over tens of millions of
years and dust and sandbling about and
it compacts with the tremendous amount
of pressure and heat it turns it to
Stone I'm like it almost kind of looks
like when you see the the nature of
these skeletons that a lot of them like
there was an event happened as if there
was a mud flood or a massive just shift
like a tidal wave of of land that had
consumed them and and that would also
explain the nature of how they become
fossilized but um I I mean I can't prove
this stuff but I mean it seems to me
that that may be an indicator of what
had happened uh to the dinosaurs and
what's to say that through a large
enough Cosmic impact that it couldn't
cause the Earth to Tumble it well or
maybe like if it's under or if it's in
the process of a current pole shift
maybe if we get nailed uh by a large
enough Comet or something maybe it could
accelerate the process I don't know I'm
just bouncing it in theory it makes
sense and you know I actually believe
there was an impactor 12 000 years ago I
just don't think it was a comment
because there's a 12 000 year impactor
cycle that matches the geomagnetic cycle
the problem is there's absolutely
nothing about an impactor
that could affect the geomagnetism
there's nothing about an impact to do
that and there's nothing that's an
amazing Point that's very interesting
about that
um that would keep repeating and in that
way eventually all the pieces will have
hit or the rest are going to miss but
the thing is the way that the sun works
is in this blast I'm talking about there
are impactors
um you know
all of these different texts talk about
the Sun going black and it's a
legitimate thing it's it's something
that's going to happen because of
what's changing the entire solar system
it's going to turn the sun black now it
doesn't mean that the sun is going to
turn off what it means is material is
going to accumulate in the Solar
atmosphere which we call the Corona and
then it's going to snap back on really
good and blast all of that material out
into space and some of that's going to
hit the planets we can talk about that
more in the time that we have but
um
yeah so
speak how much time do we have and
you're I I know you meant like talking
about Rumble but I mean like for this
event this cycle of catastrophe is it
imminent is it in our lifetimes what's
your projection yeah
um so doing the math on how fast the
magnetic pole uh is magnetic poles are
moving and how fast they're weakening
best guess is 20 30s or 20 40s I I
really like to tell myself it's going to
be 20 40s just so we have a little more
time but
um yeah there have also been some
accelerations I didn't expect
um I didn't expect the acceleration that
happened in the first couple of years of
this Millennium I didn't expect the
acceleration that happened in 2017.
especially over the Pacific sector
um people should look into when you talk
about accelerations this is measurable
we're talking about them updating
runways because you know it ties to the
compass some people aren't aware of that
but like this is measurable people like
it is accelerating the the the polls
have moved off the North and South
almost virtually completely right and is
accelerating like back in the 90s wasn't
it like it was like five miles a year
and now it's over 30 or am I or is it 60
miles do you know what how fast it's
moving I I'm drawing the a blank on the
number but I know that in the last few
decades it's accelerating yeah it's
accelerated so somewhere between 70 and
80 miles a year
um and the weakening of the field the
thing that's going to allow more space
radiation to come in which in a lot of
ways is just as dangerous if not more so
that's accelerated tremendously you know
in general the magnetic field changes
less than a percent over thousands of
years in terms of its strength how much
it protects the Earth from energy from
space but from about 1859 to the year
2000 we lost 10 percent of the feel we
have lost more than that since the year
2000. so
just to restate that usually it spends
thousands of years wavering maybe a
percent
then in 150 years we lose 10 and just
the last two decades we've lost more
than 10 percent more and so we're
talking about something that is
cascading and uh one of the most
important papers that we that we've seen
come out was actually two of them one
was a paper from Berkeley out of
California who were saying that a
magnetic reversal can happen within a
human lifetime once it begins in as
little as 80 years well we're actually
past the 80-year Mark at this point so
we're in the red zone it could happen at
any time and there was a separate one
that said that when the field actually
starts to do its flip it'll be going a
hundred times faster than it is right
now and you know for example if that
were to happen tomorrow we were to click
into a hundred times faster we'd have
six months we'd have six months and it'd
be over and I wonder if there's no way
of knowing when that's going to happen I
want people listening to know that like
what Ben is talking about right now is
me mainstream scientific literature this
is in the papers this is mainstream
science this is the kind of thing that
very few people are aware of but this
just to clarify the stuff that you're
saying right now is not conjecture this
is actual documented science and and
some people when they hear this for some
they wouldn't even believe it because
like well hold on if that was true I
would have heard about it um real quick
hey just a quick uh shout out we got
Forrest Gump WR who just said love you
Jimmy uh thank you so much just gave us
some good money uh and Kenny Lane just
said we need to lidar the Antarctica
Antarctica and yeah hey they're already
doing that they're just not going to
share it with us why do you think every
country on earth is is rushing down
there to uh do all kinds of things in
secret and I tell people I'm like you
know if nothing else they are um
in a rush to like go hoard the uh the
natural resources that are going to be
there when that thaws uh and it is
coming now um real quick uh we're gonna
move over to rumble in a few minutes but
I want to keep going on on YouTube for a
little bit
um but
I wanted to ask as far as all right so
we're seeing all of this accelerate
how do you feel it is affecting humans
uh human psyche and if I may before you
you dive into that I have one more Bible
verse because I was scrambling to bring
up my phone to bring up because I got a
whole number of these can I read this
real quick because I've read it on a few
other podcasts recently I'm going to
keep blasting it out uh because I'm not
bible thumper but I want people to just
listen to this because I'm inclined to
think that like when you look at all the
animals of the earth insects that are
are their entire life is dependent on
geomagnetic forces for direction and
other things like whales this is known
salmon
um so listen to this and this is quite
all right so this is 2 Timothy three
it's evil in the end days this is
literally describing the end times
they're gonna come and this is what will
happen so listen to this and tell me
this isn't disturbingly accurate for
what's happening today here we go
but understand this in the last days
terrible times will come for men will be
lovers of themselves lovers of money
boastful arrogant abusive disobedient to
their parents ungrateful Unholy unloving
unforgiving slanderous without
self-control brutal without love of good
traitorous Reckless conceited lovers of
pleasure rather than lovers of God
having a form of godliness but denying
its power turn away from such as these
yeah
I mean I mean now nowadays you have
people that are
um they will outright slander others
like I've recently been subject to this
where I'm sharing that the so-called
swastika that is a prehistoric symbol
that was faster bastardized by uh the
the Reich uh existed in prehistoric
times across multiple continents around
the world and just for sharing that
people will call me a Nazi it's like I'm
like that is like a knowingly false
statement that is couldn't be further
from the truth but like we live in a
time where people just because they
disagree with you and they don't like
you they'll try to destroy you so let me
let me stop myself there because I
actually was asking you the question on
how you feel this magnetic pole shift is
affecting human psyches right well I
it's interesting that the people the
kind of people who accuse you of that
are supposedly professors in this area
and they don't know how important that
symbol was in in India they don't seem
to know what the word Nazi fascist
and if they don't seem to know what
these words mean and they just throw it
right there
um
in addition to everything about the
world today basically putting a squeeze
on people which is a very real thing
um
this increased space radiation does two
things
the well I mean it does a lot of things
biophysically but in terms of psychology
it impacts
the hippocampus and causes cognitive
diminution which is a way of saying it
makes people Dumber
the other thing it does is it over
excites the locus cyrillus that anxiety
Panic fear
Center and so basically we have slowly
as the magnetic field is weakening
people getting Dumber at the same time
as they are becoming more emotionally
unstable
and more easily
um succumbing to fear and anxiety and
panic and boy I mean that's basically
your explanation for clown world right
now right
can anyone deny this like something is
off people are acting nuts like the best
explanation that can come with as like a
devil's advocate like well the
internet's making people crazy but I'm
like wait a second they didn't spin out
for a little bit and people weren't
quite this nasty in this crazy in this
cancel culture like there's something
some this has gone up a level and I feel
like anyone listening to this would
agree that it's it's becoming worse the
the social decline is accelerating like
everyone hit a one if you think that
it's getting worse you know what I mean
like it's
uh I don't know I feel like it's it's
just gone up a level that goes beyond
the realm of like the internet just
makes it easy to happen I feel like uh
The Internet's been around for a few
minutes now and it wasn't quite this bad
well you know and it it's not like
everything can be blamed on this but
this is a significant thing and this is
another one of the things that isn't
conjectured this is in the peer-reviewed
papers I mean I've got these
peer-reviewed papers I cite them in my
book
um but you know also the covid stuff
they pulled on us the uh David for
rumble hey as soon as we get to rumble
we gonna We are going to unleash the
fury we have several things that we're
gonna say I'm not cutting you off not
stopping you say whatever you want to
say I keep it real on this channel but
like when I just want to let everyone
know that it's units we'll cut over to
rumble and um we talked ahead of time
like I'm gonna we're gonna we're gonna
sling some truth bombs like I have some
stuff to say you have some stuff to say
and and that's gonna be the place to do
it sorry to cut you off I just want to
throw that no no worries
all I was gonna say is you know
we have the extra space radiation we
have things like covid we have the
economic downturn we have what we have
stuff in the world that doesn't make
sense everything from what they're
talking about with gender to basically
you can't see some you can't turn on a
music video or the Grammys or the Super
Bowl halftime show without literally
seeing demonic symbolism literal
promotion of Satanism we are getting
squeezed in every way imaginable it's
just that in addition to all the stuff
that's obvious what's not so obvious is
the fact that space radiation is
impacting Us in the exact way that makes
us more vulnerable more reactive less
ability to less able to think our way
through it as a species and individual
you know a lot of people are saying that
they believe that the sun feels brighter
and hotter I know that sounds silly to
some people but I almost wonder like I
almost feel like I'm burning easier
recently look how pacia look I swear
it's the white lights I'm far more tan
than this but just look put your
sunglasses on
um I kind of wonder if there's I can't
prove it so I'm not like trying to
suggest that this is actually happening
but do you is there any evidence that
like that is indeed the case that the
sun is getting more luminescent or is
that oh yeah oh yeah I remember the
yellow sun I remember when the sun was
yellow
it doesn't look yellow anymore
I remember like looking at the sun in as
a child in the 90s early 90s let's say
and I I swear I'm like I feel like yeah
I was a little bit more yellowish as
well
um but I find this fascinating what
you're saying about like the radiation
affecting people's psyches and one last
um not to like interject but like since
it's in front of me here's one more
passage I want to run by people because
it ties exactly into this it's Isaiah 5
20. what sorrow for those that say that
evil is good and good is evil that dark
is light and light is dark that bitter
is sweet and Sweet is bitter does that
not totally describe the clown World
backwards mentality that so many people
have that were literally praising
Injustice we are we are we are letting
criminals Go free and and persecuting
those who are innocent and it's like
people are are
joyfully participating in it and there's
no doubt in my mind when you look at all
these other these various topics like
we'll jump into in a moment involving
who people are uh as a as a biological
human being like even that is being
contested like this is legitimate
lunacy
um
what are your thoughts then on I'm
trying to think like a good segue before
we tie this over to rumble should we do
it now everyone that's listening on
YouTube the link is right there it's
right in the description all you gotta
do is press it this is streaming
simultaneously on Rumble right now and I
think is there anything you want to say
well we're still on on YouTube I mean if
in case some people aren't going to
carry over which they should because we
are gonna dive into the good stuff now
um Ben your channel is suspicious
observers observers with a zero it's a
very unique way and it's one word
suspicious observers but if you type it
in it will come right up
um and Ben Davidson
um follow Ben Davidson on Twitter but
this is not a goodbye I think that
everyone's going to want to hear the
things that we're about to dive into
over on there it is yeah
suspiciousobservers.org right
uh yeah but I mean honestly just go to
the YouTube channel that's where all the
good stuff happens and it's free so
right on so again all right everyone
listening on YouTube let me actually
give a few shout outs real quick David
Stig Hansen thank you for that you said
that's right I appreciate the generous
uh uh Super Chat and hey we're going to
rumble right now to drop some bombs it's
No Holds Barred there I'm gonna say
whatever the f uh we want I like to keep
it real and I think that people will
know yeah people know by the way you're
looking good you've been even in the gym
I see even posting games and stuff like
that on social media well done a little
bit yeah all right everybody uh here we
go it will be simultaneous on on Rumble
but at this time I'm hitting the X on
YouTube uh so hit the link that's in the
description down below that says follow
us on Rumble and we'll get into it right
over there
all right here we go